today
we're moving on and we're moving into
what's really happening with those
electrons right
and i framed this uh on monday
uh by telling you that the rutherford
atom
wasn't going to make it more than 10 to
the minus 11
seconds ish right because
classical e m would tell you that the
electron if it's going around like this
is radiating
energy and so it spirals down into that
positively charged nucleus so rutherford
got it
right in the sense that you know you got
this
all this positive charge concentrated in
this one tiny little volume in the
middle and the electrons are way out
there that's the planetary model
but we needed some new theory to
understand why the whole thing was
stable and that's where
bore comes along and that's what we're
going to talk about today
now um
we need we need to feel our oneness with
waves
okay now i think probably most of you
know
about waves but since we're going to be
talking about them a whole lot today and
as we go forward i want to make sure
we're all on the same page
right so here's a wave well we know
about water waves they move a meter a
second sound waves a little faster
right and you got these characteristics
of a wave right the frequency
of the wave right the wavelength
and so i just want to make sure that
we're all together on this
um because we're going to be
talking about these variables a lot
right so if you have like a wavelength
that might be in meters all right how
many meters do you have
per wave okay we're getting somewhere
here if you have the frequency and i'll
use this
notation here you could use f you might
see f sometimes i like using u
and if you have the frequency well
that's going to be the number
of waves per second for example
right and so the speed is going to be
the two of them multiplied together now
i know a lot of you have seen this but
again i want to get it up here
uh so it's going to be meters per second
if
if these are the the units that i'm
using seconds and meters right
okay now uh if your light
lights as in light then uh you have a
speed that is a constant in vacuum and
we know that right so
so the speed of light right so for light
let's put that right underneath
for light okay
the speed is c
which equals three times ten to the
eighth
meters per second okay just getting some
good stuff
so if i wanted to know for example um
you know how to go back and forth
between frequency and wavelength
for light well i can just use this
relationship
right so let's put an example up there
right so
so for example if you're like red light
okay so if you're red light then
you might have a a frequency of around
let's say 450 there's a range but 450
terahertz
would be a frequency okay and so now i
can get the wavelength because i have
that relationship so the wavelength
for red light is c over nu which is
going
ah which is going to be equal to
3 times 10 to the eighth meters per
second
divided by 450
times 10 to the 12th per second right
that's the
the measurement of hertz is one over
seconds right that's frequency
right one over seconds okay um now
uh that gives me a number that's pretty
it seems like it's pretty small
zero zero zero zero
zero zero six six seven
meters and and so we could
use a different unit like nanometers
right which is just 10 to the minus
ninth so we could call that the
wavelength of
red light 667 nanometers now
i'm doing this all slowly and carefully
because we're going to be doing this a
lot and so i want to make sure that
you're comfortable
with this and we're going to add
something to this in just a minute
so that's like oh if i was blue light
where's blue light let's put blue light
i'm gonna leave red light here
and we'll put blue light right above it
so you can see them together so blue
might be something like a frequency of
650 terahertz so higher frequency
and that would give you a wavelength of
something like
460 nanometers
i'm putting these both here because i'll
be comparing other aspects
of these colors later okay
now comes back now that's our oneness
moment with waves and light
and now we come back to our story our
detective story of what's happening
inside of atoms
right and it really requires us to go
back i said
bohr had some postulates about
quantization
this there was work going on at the time
already related to quantization okay
now what and so so i want to share with
you that work
because it's what inspired bohr and then
we'll do the bohr model
but also just i want to get you thinking
about what this all means
right so if you think about music like
you can think about these two
instruments
this might feel like the violin might
feel like something where you can just
play continuous notes
whereas here you can't right it's
discrete what you can play i can't play
any notes in between
right something is discrete it's
quantized
well that's pretty obvious right you
look at those yeah okay that makes sense
but what about there's some things that
aren't as obvious like here
oh notice what's in the calendar right
that's a screen now a screen from far
enough
away might not look quantized
but then when you look up you know you
look at it closely
it is it's pixels there's nothing in
between
there's nothing in between yeah the
thing is that these people at the time
people
thought about the world in a certain way
there you know there's some things where
it's just like obvious they're violins
like light and then they're like wait a
second these things are acting like
xylophones
what's going on and that's really what
you know so plank's contribution
was really he was one of the first kind
of deep
thinkers to to to talk about
quantization
and it was quantization of light
it was quantization of light and so
what he what he said and this is
together with einstein and i'll show you
what i signed in a minute so it's called
the plank einstein relation
and and what he said is that the energy
of a photon so plank
why did i just go all caps i don't know
i don't know there's a reason
plank einstein he said oh they
they said that the energy
for light the energy is
related to the frequency through a
constant
and so in particular e equals
h times the frequency
now this was revolutionary it might just
look like a simple relationship oh and
by the way this is a constant
named planck's constant
i'm going lowercase planck's constant
and it it like other constants it has
a value that doesn't change so so
that value for plank's constant is in
i'll give it to you in two different
units so we have it up here six point
two
six uh no six point six two
sorry six two uh six
times ten to the minus 34
joules second okay
or it's also equal to 4.136
times 10 to the minus 15th
electron volts seconds notice the units
are in energy times time planck's
constant
okay i mean and you can see that it must
be because this is energy and this is
one over time
right the frequency so so it's got to
have those units for that to work
but this just did i make a mistake no
i'm worried the dates are still hitting
me hard i'm still thinking about that
having nightmares 100 years off 90 years
off
i'm good so what this told
what what they saw is that
um you know light
light had a frequency but it also had
somehow this unit of energy
a unit a discrete
unit of energy that you can now
calculate using planck's constant right
and and and that was revolution that was
not what people thought
and it really all came home in what
einstein did which was
uh the experiment said he won the nobel
prize for his his deeper thinking was in
relativity but he won the nobel prize
for this because it was
it was absolutely essential
to further this idea of quantization and
show
show it with an experiment and because
it was so important i want to share that
experiment because what einstein did was
really quite
amazing he shined light on a metal
and what he saw so this is
called the photoelectric effect photo
electric effect
and this is where you take a piece of
metal
okay and you know they knew there were
electrons in there right
and that that discovery had happened so
they knew their electrons
and they also knew if you hit this metal
with energy the electrons could come off
i mean after all that's what the cathode
ray tube was
right it was electrons coming off of a
piece of metal
and and in that experiment you hook up a
voltage but here
he shined light and so if you take for
example
um different frequencies of light and
you shine them on the same piece of
metal so let's go
red and then let's go green
and then let's go blue
right you shine now if you shine
red light on the metal nothing happened
nothing happened and they said okay we
know if you just crank up the intensity
of the light something's got to come off
you're putting all this
energy no why because the
particles the the packets the quantized
amounts of energy that that kind of
light can have
is determined here
so what einstein says well okay then
these must be
particles they must have some energy
associated with the particle that
follows this relationship e equals h nu
and notice
that doesn't depend on intensity it just
depends on frequency
so that so i might be hitting this metal
with more and more of them but each one
only has
the same amount of energy limited by
that relationship
so if i want to hit those electrons with
more energy
i got to change the frequency right
and so what what was found in this
experiment is that well maybe here
you get nothing so here you get
nothing how am i gonna write that no
okay
nothing i just won't write it here maybe
you get
electrons and here maybe you get
faster electrons
right electrons because these have
different
these fundamental particles of energy of
light
have different energies right so so if
we now we can calculate it
we can calculate the energy of that red
light
and we can calculate the energy of the
blue light right because i have now
e equals h nu
and if i plug it in which i won't do you
get something like 1.8
electron volts and if you do the same
thing for blue
you get from the planck einstein
relation you get the energy is 2.7
electron volts right so what einstein
did in this experiment
which was so crucial is he
measured he met he didn't you know he
changed the frequency of light that you
shine on this metal
and what he saw is that there was
nothing nothing nothing nothing
and then all of a sudden you literally
had if you plot the kinetic energy
of the i'll write it out here ejected
electron
right so that's what's being plotted
there
then there and you plot that versus the
ah i said i wasn't going to use f versus
the frequency of the light
nothing nothing nothing and then all of
a sudden there's a linear relationship
between them that explains it
because these things were made of these
these uh these particles
that were called photons right so
photons
now while this was blowing their minds
and winning prizes and all that bore
came along now remember
this is what i mean by dates okay apart
from the dates
okay we know now there was a lot of
time between those experiments um
especially dalton and thompson
um and and that's where we were
on monday right and but so borer
was looking at all this remember he
wrote the paper where he said it is of
it is it is with great interest
the rutherford adam meaning it's wrong
it needs fixing
meanwhile boar's looking over at
einstein and plank and he's like wait a
second
let me get some of that quantization
stuff
because you know if it works for light
what if it also works for electrons what
if it also works for electrons right
and so so he's looking at this stuff
going on with plank and eisen and he
applied it
to the electron in rutherford's atom
that's what he did
that's what boar did he said you guys
got your light thing
i'm going after the atom and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to make a
just a actually a fairly simple
postulate
why is that up there let's go i'm going
to say
that the for me the quantization is
going to happen with the angular
momentum
so bohr came along and he said
that the angular momentum of the
electron so
l equals mvr right this remember we we
listed the board postulates and one of
them was
that newtonian mechanics would hold
angular momentum mvr but
there's something added to it he said
that that angular momentum could only
have discrete
values quantization
so he said that this is quantized and he
was specific
he said it could only be some number
some integer
times planck's constant divided by 2 pi
why not when in doubt divide by 2 pi
right as you all know that has to do
with
just making math easier now
that's the angular momentum and he said
it's quantized an n
n is the is the key here right because n
is this thing
that says that it is must be
some unit right this is like the unit
it's like that photon energy right comes
in units and
so but it comes in units of integers
right
so you could have one or or you could
have two
or three but but not 1.5 right
that's quantization so n had to be 1
2 three it had to be some integer
and oh here we go
watch this we're gonna call it a quantum
number
oh i should have written that in all
caps
quantum thank you for that thanks it
it's a it's our first quantum number and
we've only known each other
for a week a week here we are
we're quantizing things quantum number
because
it's a number that counts quantumness
quantization this is how you get the
quantization
from this so it's a quantum number now
here's the thing
i will not derive bohr's uh model for
you
i will tell you what it is um and
if you want um you can you know we you
can derive you can look up the
derivation it's actually
really fairly straightforward you know
it basically has to do
with this one assumption quantization
of the angular momentum of that electron
combined with f equals ma and the
electron is stable
it's not accelerating in right and when
you do that
what you get let's put this
no let's put that back up
so what you get with bohr's model
is the following you get
you get three extremely important
outcomes okay first
you get that the radius of
that electron is quantized
then you get that its energy
the energy that it's allowed to have is
also
quantized and finally you get that its
transitions
are you got it thank you
quantized oh
so if you plug stuff in and you do the
bohr derivation
for the hydrogen atom what you get is
that the radius
is of that electron is equal to n
squared times a constant divided by the
atomic number
and this constant is called
the bohr radius it's got a value of
0.0529 nanometers
and it's also called the the bohr radius
if you want
but that's its value right and then if
you do the same now if you look at
energy so energy the equation for that
comes out to be minus 13.6 times
the atomic number squared divided by n
squared in units of ev
those are the two key results that come
from bohr's postulates and from bohr
doing this doing that
right and we're going to talk about each
one of these all right
so if i okay
okay so let's go one at a time
no okay
so let's talk about the radius for a
minute
if i um let's talk about the radius so
if i
if i look at the radius and i'm a
nucleus here
so i've got like some positive charge in
the middle and some nucleons and stuff
what i'm saying i'm sorry some nuclei uh
neutrons uh is that the electron
can only be at certain values
the distance this distance r
right can only be at these values and
that's dictated
by the quantization number the quantum
number n
equals 1 would be the closest you can
see that from the formula
right and n equals 2
and so on and this is not necessarily
drawn to scale
you can see that for n equals one and z
equals one
right it the electron is simply at the
distance
of the constant 0.5 ish angstroms
0.05 nanometers right
at n equals two it's four times that
right oh
yeah the z is the atomic number
right um and and and that comes in
let's put that here
and that comes in because it tells us
how many positive
charges there are how many protons there
are
in the nucleus right and that comes in
when you do f equals m a that's how it
comes into the bohr
equations okay
now um and r is a distance and n is the
quantum number and a naught is a
constant
z is the atomic number in both cases
now um so so this would be four okay now
this is mind-blowing because it
it tells you that that's where the
electrons are
in the atom orbit right in the atom um
they're but they're only those distances
remember quantization means nothing else
but think about that i'm saying that
that electron can't be anywhere else it
must be this distance
or it must be this distance so this was
a big deal
people like what right it didn't it
didn't
compute it didn't make sense but this is
what they were starting to see
that this was the only way to explain
what they saw
which we'll come to when we talk about
transitions and when we you know so this
would be the radius
and when you look at the energy
it's just as i'm going to use yeah i'll
put it here
you know if you so you take that
equation for the energy
of an electron in an atom and you take
z equals one so let's take you know if z
equals one then the energy
is quantized and it's minus 13.6
divided by n squared electron volts
and and if i just draw this right as
like
energy going up okay
so if i just draw this then what that
means is that i've got one line down
here
you know showing kind of the energy
level so this should be minus
uh uh 13.6 ev
and then i've got another line here and
this would be minus
3.4 ev and then i've got another one
here
minus let's see 1.5 ish ev
okay and i'm going to start to get
crowded as you can see they're going to
get closer and closer
until you get to some level here
which would be like n equals infinity
right and and
and then above that zero right above
that
it's free the electron is free
when it's n is infinity when it's gone
through all the quantum numbers up to
infinity
it's free and that is called ionization
taking it out of the atom
and making it not part of an atom
anymore but just out there free able to
do what it wants
that's you've ionized it you've taken it
out we'll come back to this concept
multiple times okay these are the energy
levels for an electron and they are also
quantized they can only be this value or
only that value or only that value they
cannot be anything else in between
that was revolutionary at the time right
so this would be like n equals 1 sorry
that's not
e that's ev n equals 1
and equals 2 and so on
now the third point that i made is that
it also tells us about transitions
and um
and this was also you know you know this
was also
absolutely essential and this was the
key piece
to understanding what they saw right
so and so we'll get to that in a few
minutes um what do i mean by a
transition i mean that an energy
an electron is in an atom at some level
and it moves to another level okay
now um now the point is that if it can
only be in these discrete quantized
levels then when it moves from one to
another
those changes in energy are also
discrete values there are only certain
changes in energy that that electron can
experience
and there's even more which is that what
can cause those changes or what happens
as a result of those
changes is the interaction with light
and we're all the way back to here
photons think about this way
when you know if i take a ball and i
have it up here it's got some mgh in it
right and i drop it and now it's got
some ke
all right i had this more energy
was in gravitation i was stored in mgh
gravitational potential energy
and then i let it go well for an
electron
this is its ground state this is the
kind of you know
happy place so this would be like a
ground state
right and these
would be all
excited states it would be like
excited states so that would be
like lifting the electron up and letting
go but when you let it go
it's not kinetic energy that that
transfers into
it's photon energy huh
photon energy gets emitted from
electrons changing their levels
in an atom light
is is an absolutely intricate part of
this system
and not only that but everything is
quantized
ah i almost need a moment
but i'm okay i'm gonna keep going this
was
a big deal a really big deal
right because now i can tell you
okay there we go because now i could
tell you for example
that if that's the second orbit in
hydrogen and that's the first orbit
i can tell you what frequency light is
emitted if you go from
n equals two to n equals one right
because the change in energy
from n equals 2 to
n equals 1 is nothing more than
minus 13.6 ev
times well it's the final state minus
the initial state
right the final state is one over one
squared and the initial state is one
over two squared
right all i've done is pull out the 13.6
but these are just
you know the minus certain these are
just the bohr model energies
and i'm just taking the difference you
know this is equal to e
f minus e i it's the change in energy
right so in this case it's minus 10.2
electron volts
and going from the second orbit quantize
orbit down to the first
oh and i can now tell you what because
of what we did in the beginning
that that would emit a photon of
frequency
2.5 times
10 to the 15th hertz
that's the energy difference and that
energy goes into producing a photon
goes into producing a photon and we can
tell you exactly what that frequency is
okay so these are the kinds of
transitions
that the bohr model explains and it
explains energy
changing from electron transitions to
photons
right and okay so what are the
implications of this oh there's the
question that i just answered
okay if this is hydrogen if this is
hydrogen
z equals one okay
ah the implications of this are
groundbreaking and it explained what
people were seeing because you got
you we talked about angstroms already
angstrom looked up and he's like well
you guys think it's a rainbow
but i'm not seeing that i'm seeing
discrete lines all over the place
and that's what he saw when he looked at
the sun don't look at the sun
it's not a good idea but angstrom did
and and and you know now he said well
but there's all these lines and
the the wavelengths that he tabulated
happened to come on this sort of
thousands of angstrom
kind of scale right and so he liked that
and chemists love it
and that's why the angstrom is named
what it is 10 to the minus 10th meters
uh okay oh chemists love it because a
bond is a few angstroms
spectroscopists spectroscopists like
nanometers
they're like you know thousands are too
big we don't like thousands we want to
work with hundreds
so spectroscopists use nanometers uh uh
other people chemists use angstroms i
say can't we all
uh just really get along and it's fine
don't make spectroscopists
angry really i did it once
okay now on friday you are going to get
you are going to get the most accurate
spectroscope that has been made by
humans
and uh and in your in your goodie bag
and you'll be able to look
at the fact that the world is not
continuous these
frequencies wavelengths that are coming
out
are not continuous if you take a tube of
h2 gas and you apply like
an enormous voltage to it you will
excite
electrons in the h2 molecules
as they go back down they will emit
photons and what will you see
only certain values well this is what
people were doing
they were looking out into the universe
which by the way is 75 percent hydrogen
right and and they're like well but we
really so the height the hydrogen
economy
um
we uh we they were looking out
and seeing discrete lines all over the
place
how to explain it the bohr model
is what explained it you will be able to
see these discrete lines yourselves with
the goodie bag on friday
right but if you do this this is what
you might see from hydrogen
okay and and
you know there were a lot of people
trying to understand this at the time
balmer and rydberg and i'm not going to
go through they came up with sort of
partial formula they were exp they were
empirically based
but bohr it was only the bohr model that
could explain it all it was only the
bohr model and the reason is
that that all the transitions were out
there
and you need the you need the complete
picture of these changes in energy
between these levels you need to know
about that to understand all those
transitions
and at the time it was a real thing if
you were like i want to get something
named after myself
in science you'd be like let me go and
find a new set of transitions
which are just basically lines right
it's that you're not seeing a continuous
spectrum in some part
of space you're instead seeing discrete
lines and look at this
right so like like lyman all you know
you can go down to n equals one like we
did there
right two to one so from here to here
but you could also go from three uh down
to one you can also go from four
right and that's a series oh then you
could also transition not from
not to one but to two or the three in
each one of those a series then i think
finally they're like okay no more names
after the fund we're done
with naming but all those series are
still there those are the allowed
transitions
okay so you can you can also imagine
that it's not
just a mission all right so we've been
talking about a mission you get these
lines when
when an electron goes down in energy
remember like the ball the mgh
goes down it gives off photons in these
quantized energies but it can be the
opposite
you could shine light so i could get a
continuous spectrum here and
shine it on an atom
and that atom absorbs light literally by
exciting electrons an electron is in
some state maybe the ground state
and some energy comes along that exactly
takes it up to one of these states
oh but it can't it can't
sort of take you up there it's got to
take you there
quantization that's why you don't that's
why you see these
these lines here right these are the
places where
that atom can absorb a photon because it
exactly corresponds to a transition
from one discrete level to another
right so it works both ways absorbing
photon energy
promoting electrons up right
and when we when we do x-rays we just
ionize everything
but right now we're staying within the
potential of the atom
so we're staying within these levels
right
um absorbing or emitting
energy so i could answer questions like
this you know if you look at a question
like this
i forget i think this might be from a a
couple years ago quiz
so you might get something like this
tomorrow no
you won't i just looked at a few faces
and no because we're talking about it
today
so you wouldn't get it tomorrow because
remember you only get quizzed on things
that we did
you know ending on monday right it
wouldn't be fair otherwise
but next week okay
what's the lowest energy photon shown
which one is it these are photons now we
think of these as photons
red high wavelength
lower energy right okay good that was
that was over here
okay now what about what transition
gives the line at 639 nanometers
hello ximena 639 nanometers
okay so i want to know what electron
transition did that
well to solve that problem to solve that
problem i need to do some erasing
maybe i'll just draw it in here because
if you have uh what you have is minus
13.6
ev right times
i'm assuming z equals one because
did i say it was hydrogen i did
hydrogen z equals one so z goes away
right
one squared so minus 13.6 ev times
uh okay one over the final state squared
minus one over the initial quantum state
squared
quantum number squared and and so so you
you know
that so that's going to equal 639
nanometers which we now
know we can convert things to plank and
einstein into an energy
we now know that a photon energy it's
that photon
that that unit that discrete unit
that does it and this is 1.94
ev because it comes from 639 nanometers
back and forth back and forth we got to
get into that mode
and into that mood back and forth energy
frequency wavelength and so i won't do
the math here but the answer comes into
something like
it's the uh 4
to three four
to three is the transition that gives
you that
okay we're not going to go salute
we're not going to go kind of all you
know this is a fairly simple one to see
we're not going to go like n
equals 528 to n equals 7 000 and
you know but but some simple kind of
back and forth just get
get into the that mode of looking at
these transitions
as changes in energy which means the
emission or absorption
of a photon that's what i want you to
get out of this
and and you can go further than that and
answer questions like power
questions right so here's a question
if your favorite radio station
broadcasts at a frequency of 107.9
i'm not saying that's mine but you gotta
group out
and a power output of 50 kilowatts how
many photons are emitted
by the transmitter each second i just
want to give you this as another example
of thinking about this
light energy right light to energy
photons particles and and here
you know here you can you can get that
by simply knowing what power is and
if you know what power is it's watts per
second
sorry watts is joules per second um and
so
so the energy here is h nu and i won't
go through all the math but i'll
leave the answer here you get 7.12
times 10 to the minus 26
joules per photon
how did i get that i got that because i
know the frequency
why am i using joules remember i put
them both up there jules
ev ah because i know my power
which is 50 kilowatts
which is 50 000
joules per second right and so i've got
joules in the power i just decided to
stick with joules
joules ev joules eb back and forth
they're just units
right you you should if you're not
familiar with changing back and forth
you should
do a little practice and this gives you
something like 7 times
10 to the 29th
photons
per second right so you can think about
power
photons light energy if i shine that
many
if i shine that many on on uh
on on einstein's metal will the
electrons come
off that seems like a lot
we don't know because we need to know
how much energy it takes to liberate the
electron and then that ties into the
frequency
radio waves are much lower energy much
much lower energy
okay now this gets me to why this
matters and that's how i want to end
today's lecture the last five minutes um
because you know we talked about
emission
electrons transitioning from their
discrete orbitals
right as a way of emitting or absorbing
and so if you have different atoms
there's hydrogen these are the
absorption
lines absorption lines okay
carbon has absorption lines oxygen
nitrogen sulfur sodium
lots of things have absorption lines why
does this matter
well of course because of the
refrigerator
but this is i love this pot this is a
plot of the refrigerator
and okay this is the size of the
refrigerator
as a function of euro the date only goes
to 2002 but it's roughly stable now does
anybody know what's limiting the size of
the refrigerator
look it was going up and up and up a lot
and then it stopped
anybody know what limit's at
it's the width of the doorway it's the
width of the doorway
that's why we don't that's why people
get a second refrigerator right
and and so uh okay but and there's
energy use
oh energy start program big deal
big deal but i'm talking about
refrigerators for a different reason
i'm talking about refrigerators because
until the 1980s
the way we did cooling was with a
chemical
called chlorofluorocarbon this is a
chemistry class and we're going to be
talking about
when we talk about why this matters we
connect to the chemistry
well the chemistry there was critical
there was a molecule there
called chlorofluorocarbon or cfc and
the thing about that molecule is
that it its absorption
the chlorofluorocarbon so let's write it
down here
c uh cl3
f okay there's a gas phase
so we put the little lower script g
that molecule has its own absorption
okay it has its own absorption and it
has its own reaction and so do other
things
oh but okay it has it has a really
important reaction
because when it absorbs uv rays
when it absorbs then it it doesn't just
like then
like electrons get pumped up no the
whole thing reacts
and so this thing degrades into c
cl2 f
plus chlorine gas and that's once it's
up
you know like maybe in the atmosphere
right which it was getting released
all the time because the refrigerators
and the thing is that the chlorine gas
would then react with ozone
and this would go to clo
okay plus o2 and here's the problem
i mean we're already at a problem but
now it's a big problem because
you can already tell but i've got clo
and that's really reactive
so what happens is clo which was a gas
i'm just being careful here with my
subscripts
would react with atomic oxygen to give
you
o2 and the chlorine atom back
and here's the thing now i've got my
chlorine atom again these are very
reactive atoms in the atmosphere they
love
ozone and and so this
this cycle for one cfc molecule
would happen a hundred thousand times
roughly
before that that chlorine kind of goes
away and does something else
a hundred thousand ozone molecules per
cfc
why does that matter well it matters
because oh i love this plot
this is the energy of light from the sun
hitting our planet so this is the
the energy that you get right and and
look at this
this is the sun at the top of the
atmosphere here it is on earth the red
look at these things here
if you see in if you could only see in
this spectrum
the world would be dark because there's
no light on the planet why because it's
all absorbed in the upper atmosphere by
water
absorption it's the same principle bor
bohr's idea of electrons getting getting
promoted when they absorb
light is happening and it's protecting
us
because right here see that's the uv low
wavelength high energy uv o3 look at
that
look at what it's taking out that little
sliver of yellow
is critical and ozone was doing the job
and it still is but if we tear all that
ozone out with these cfcs
we have a crisis and that led to what is
one of the greatest uh
uh policy decisions which was made in
1987 it's called the montreal protocol
to essentially ban globally ban the u.s
led this
this is a great example of how policy is
so critical the u.s
led this effort to ban cfcs and we avoid
we're almost back to
normal ozone levels and we avoid this
and by the way if this
had happened the prediction at the time
was roughly 280 million additional cases
of skin cancer
over over this generation this is a very
big deal
and it all comes back
to absorption of electrons by atoms and
molecules
see you guys on friday
you